in just a few days Avengers in game will
be re-released into the theaters with a
new post-credit scene
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
initially everybody thought that this
new post-credit scene which is a deleted
scene from avengers endgame was going to
be the scene of Tony talking to his
adult daughter Morgan Stark in the soul
world however today we have learned some
new information about what will be seen
in the new post-credit scene for
Avengers and Games re-release and it
involves the Hulk
quick reminder to subscribe to my
channel to enter my marvel legends item
giveaway I'll be picking three new
winners at four hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers so we recently
found out that in some select theaters
the Avengers in-game re-release will
start off with a message from the Russo
brothers we also know that there's going
to be a new special tribute to Stanley
which I'm sure all of the fans will
definitely enjoy we're also going to be
getting a spider-man fire from home
sneak peek so for those of you who are
really excited about spider-man far from
home be sure to go see the re-release of
Avengers and game to get a brand new
sneak peek at it but then we're going to
get a new deleted scene of The Hulk as
the New Avengers in-game post-credit
scene now as far as deleted scenes with
the Hulk go there really aren't too many
that were cut from the movie at least
not many that were mentioned and only
one really stands out and that is Bruce
Banner in the gamma chamber becoming
Professor Hulk in Avengers in game they
sort of just threw professor Hulk at us
we see Bruce Banner in the beginning of
the movie and then the Avengers go and
kill thanos there's a five-year gap and
then boom
professor Hulk and Bruce doesn't really
tell us much he just says that he spent
some time in a gambit chamber and he
combined himself with the Hulk he has
the best of both worlds now 18 months in
a gamble I put the brains and the Brawn
together and now look at me best of both
worlds
easiness but initially an Avengers in
game they did show him becoming
professor Hulk this scene was ultimately
cut out of the movie but now with the
report that the post-credits scene is
going to be about the Hulk everybody is
thinking that this is going to be the
new post-credit scene it would be
interesting to see Bruce Banner and the
Hulk fused together as one in the gamma
chamber and this could also mean that
there's more of the Hulk to come in the
MCU we do know that Mark Ruffalo and
Kevin Feige the president of Marvel
Studios met many times to talk about the
future of the hulk and in a Q&A on
reddit not too long ago with kevin feige
he did say that there are a lot of
unused hulk ideas that him and Mark
Ruffalo have come up with and not too
many people were too excited about the
Hulk story arc in Avengers endgame yes
he performed the snap and brought
everybody back but many fans were
disappointed that we didn't really get
to see him Hulk out in the movie so it's
nice that we're going to be getting this
deleted scene of the Hulk but hopefully
this means that the Hulk is not done in
the MCU there have not been any reports
that say Mark Ruffalo is done playing
the Hulk and no reports saying that this
is the last we'll see of the Hulk in the
MCU and again like I said Kevin Feige
and Mark Ruffalo met before Avengers in
game to talk about future ideas for the
Hulk and again Kevin Feige said that
there are many ideas that they came up
with that are not used yet so perhaps we
didn't see too much of the Hulk Hulk out
because there's going to be new versions
of the Hulk coming to the MCU many fans
hoping to eventually see a world breaker
hulk or a maestro hulk at some point in
time in the MCU but we will be getting a
new hulk scene in avengers endgame with
the re-release that is coming out this
weekend so be sure to comment with what
you would like to see with this new hulk
scene in avengers endgame and comment
with your favorite superhero or villain
liked the video and subscribe to my
channel so you can enter my giveaway and
stay up to date on everything relating
to Marvel as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof